authorities there giving an update on an
unfolding tragedy in florida rescue
workers desperately scouring the rubble
of a 12-story building that suddenly
collapsed around 1 30 a.m
authorities saying at least 99 residents
are still unaccounted for but there's
still hope for survivors as you just
heard
from the officials there steve harrigan
is at the scene in surfside you've been
there since this morning steve
can you give us an update as to where we
are now
dana i think the key headline coming out
of that press conference from officials
here in surfside
is that there is still sound coming from
the rubble
it's not clear that that sound is coming
from humans
it is a banging they're not sure where
it's coming from no
human voices involved but there is a
sound and for
officials here as well as the governor
of florida this is still very much a
search and rescue operation
the other thing is they say it's
deceptive much of that work much of that
effort to rescue people
is going on underneath the surface under
the parking garage it is there that they
are cutting
drilling digging working with dogs
tunneling through
to try to find and rescue anyone so much
of the work going on underground
and still some hope as urban search and
rescue teams continue
they'll continue to work throughout the
night tonight to try to rescue as many
as 99 people
still unaccounted for dana steve uh
we're going to take it around the table
here of course everyone you're watching
the five and we will um take it to
questions now katie would you like to
start if you have a question for steve
yeah steve are there any updates on
the the building and what they think
caused this the press conference didn't
give much insight into
maybe what was behind this i know that
there's an investigation going on but i
think a lot of people are looking at
this and saying how could this possibly
happen uh especially in the middle of
the night when people are
sleeping certainly the mayor of surfside
is one of those saying
how this is bizarre on a scale of one to
ten it's a ten
this shouldn't happen it couldn't happen
that's one extreme
the other is florida international
university investigators saying
that this building has been sinking at
two millimeters a year since the 1990s
there has been a lawsuit by residents of
the building for cracks in the building
leakage from the pool construction on
the building a major construction next
to the building
right now all we have is theories why
possibly this tragedy could have
occurred
but no clear answer yet as to what
caused the collapse
geraldo any comment on that or a
question for steve well i think the
investigation will
uh will reveal what i fear will be
something much more
widespread these buildings built on sand
you know they sink things happening but
steve the question i have for you
this seems so everyone is so
measured in their remarks this seems to
me an
unfolding catastrophe if 99 people are
still unaccounted for
we're hearing the officials speak of uh
of sounds of banging here or there
but that building as i understand it
pancaked so there's not a whole lot of
space
in the building uh that has collapsed uh
is there a is there a sense of that
menace is there a sense
that this is a tragedy of a really
significant proportion steve
i think we haven't gotten there yet i
think there's still hope
and still tremendous fear and anxiety
but
the fact that it could be 99 has not set
in here yet
and you're right to point out the
destruction is incredible when you do
look at it it's not just the edge of
this building that was ripped away it
was actually
roughly half of 136 condominium units
and it the pancake itself of rubble is
about three stories high
with no space in between so it's a
devastating scene
hard to imagine people coming out of
there they did rescue 36 overnight
but just two pulled from the rubble
jesse well i just have a comment i spoke
to a builder today
who said cracks had to have been visible
and now you heard people say
yes there was a litigation over cracks
and because it was a pancake that only
means one thing
this building had to have been built
structurally wrong
and that's on the architect the
developer and the contractor and if they
have a review every 40 years
they were in the review process to pass
the inspection
the reporting is that they were already
talking about making structural changes
in order to pass inspection
and if you add that to the usa today
report that says that there was a survey
done in the 90s that said the structure
was sinking you have to ask yourself
when did the association
know about this and if they didn't do
anything about it
you're going to see one of the biggest
lawsuits in florida history
because it's negligent homicide and
that's really the key to this
is knowing when these
structural imbalances were
and doing nothing about it and that is
just a horrible horrible tragedy
steve harrigan thank you for being with
us we will continue with more on the
five we'll be right back